formerly the best foreign language film
award was an honorary one voted by the
Board of Governors this year however a
different method was employed
organizations similar to the Academy and
countries all over the world were
charged with the task of selecting their
outstanding motion pictures from these
many entries the Academy members
nominated five films and then by secret
ballot chose the winner representatives
of the nominated motion pictures are
here with us tonight as guests of the
Academy they have come from the Orient
and from Europe to them I extend on
behalf of the Academy a very special
welcome the nominated films are from
Denmark
Keva TOC produced by Oh Dolph guard
Olsen from France
Gervaise produced by Hannah Dorfman from
Germany the Captain epiphanic produced
by Walter copal anelia straightish from
Italy La Strada
produced by Dino De Laurentiis and Carlo
Ponti from Japan Harper Burma produced
by caucus she I'm sorry
Masai you keep Akashi the winner please
La Strada
the dealer honest will accept thank you
gradually this hour belong to federico
fellini is in Odense